with DARPA support we have developed an
interactive system for the efficient
inspection of multiple videos recorded
along spatially similar paths but at
different times the system enables a
human sequence analyst to detect
differences between the two videos the
system is based on the techniques
described in the paper video matching by
peterson and seth teller which appeared
in the Proceedings of siggraph 2004 the
idea is to determine the frame of the
second video that has visually closest
to each frame of the primary video this
secondary frame is then warped to match
the primary frame and the difference
between the two frames is generated as a
false color image the sequence analysts
can see at a glance which parts of the
scene have changed with the addition of
georeference tags to each video we can
search for matching frames far more
efficiently and can flag regions where
differences exist in a map based
interface this interface quickly tells
the sequence analysts which regions of
the map contains areas in which the
system detected a substantial difference
in the scene between the times that the
primary and secondary videos were
required
here is an example of a clear difference
found by our system the system saw that
these trash cans in the secondary video
were not present when the primary video
was recorded it flagged this segment as
a difference and the trash cans appear
clearly in the difference video one of
the strengths of our system is that it
can detect differences that may easily
escape a human observer in this video
the system detected two people walking
down some train tracks it is hard to
perceive the people by I even when
comparing the secondary video to the
primary video but the system detected it
and a look at the difference video shows
the two people clearly the system can
also match videos recorded in largely
featureless environments such as deserts
in this example a simulated explosive
device was buried near a fence even in
this largely homogeneous video the
system can still spot the difference as
shown in the difference video the
current system is only a prototype it
serves as a proof of concept that a
system based on computer vision
techniques can perform useful change
detection across long video sequences
acquired in a variety of environments